au coeur de chartres médiévale la rue
des changes
les commerçants passe la monnaie est
conclu leurs affaires dans la grande
salle des comptes 7 à aulas n'a subi ni
bombardement ni projet haussmanniens et
demande à être redécouverte
on est vraiment sur un bâtiment
exceptionnel un bâtiment qui est
conservée qui est quasiment encore dans
son jus avec une charpente encore
médiéval avec des fresques sur les
pignons et avec une architecture qui est
quand même particulièrement ostentatoire
est particulièrement impressionnante et
qui est l'un des rares exemples de ce
type de bâtiment france
les descendants de thibault le tricheur
souhaitait un lieu de prestige
ce sera le parloir au bourgeois quand
les comptes de chartres viennent sur
chartres il n'habite plus dans château
parce que le château est vétuste
donc ils habitent dans un bâtiment dans
un hôtel particulier qui est du côté de
la cathédrale et ici il ferait
construire un bâtiment extérieur pour la
représentation pour la justice pour
l'affirmation du pouvoir la construction
de ce bâtiment correspond aussi avec
l'époque où le comté de chartres qui
avant dépendez de blois revient dans
l'escarcelle du roi en étant réintégrer
au domaine royal
les archéologues font remonter cette
construction à 12 180 grâce à la
datation des cercles du bois des poutres
le bâtiment est vivant il a des
ouvertures qui sont créés d'autres qui
sont fermés et ce qui va nous intéresser
ici ça va être de chercher où est ce
qu'on peut avoir des ouvertures des
entrées des sorties des escaliers des
passages qui sont différents et tout ce
qu'on peut avoir dans la mise en scène
du pouvoir
une fresque de chevalier combattants a
bien souffert
sa peinture se détache du mur elle sera
compliqué à restaurer après chaque
fouille les responsables des opérations
compile les données
ce travail long et fastidieux prend
souvent plus de temps que les
découvertes c'est vraiment ça la
complexité on urbain c'est que comme on
a deux mille ans d'histoire
ceux qui sont venus après elle a donc
pas trop fait attention comme nous on
fait attention aujourd'hui quoi
sauvegarder la mémoire coûte cher 6
archéologues en cdd ne seront pas
renouvelés lors des chantiers futurs